[Música]
o ensino superior universitário está na
agenda de todos e de todas constituiu
certo do desenvolvimento sustentável do
nosso planeta
sem dúvida nenhuma acredito que todos
estejam conscientes da importância e do
caráter determinado do desenvolvimento
do ensino superior para a sobrevivência
do ser humano nosso planeta para
sobrevivência dos ecossistemas
nós vemos o ensino superior como núcleo
central de todo o sistema complexo com o
movimento circular permanente que é o
desenvolvimento sustentável do planeta
terra no esquema podem ver é que pode
significar que realmente o núcleo maciço
de todo esse sistema constitui o
desenvolvimento deste é deste planeta
está a gira à volta do ensino superior
universitário gira à volta da educação
está aprovado e mais do que comprovado
pela análise das estatísticas de fatos
pela análise das evidências que os
países mais estáveis
os países mais desenvolvidos são aqueles
que realmente fizeram uma aposta muito
séria na educação no desenvolvimento do
sistema educativo integrado integral
nós consideramos que este núcleo central
que é o ensino universitário e que
promove uma dinâmica interna própria e
que internamente promove o equilíbrio de
forças que retroalimenta o próprio
sistema também tem alto tietê para todo
o sistema global
podemos até fazer uma análise mais
globalizante a nível do planeta por onde
o comércio mas também podemos rebaixar
de escala e
chegando à escala dos países ea escala
mais localizada
senhores e senhoras não é dúvida de que
as tensões menos evoluídas também são
aquelas que menos apostar na educação
kv dão exemplo enorme num país sem
recursos que conseguiu capitalizar
daquilo que é o maior recurso do nosso
planeta que é o ser humano investindo na
educação conseguiu atingir níveis de
desenvolvimento é comparáveis a países
com muitos recursos naturais
nós observamos esse esquema podemos ver
que a nossa visão é de um sistema
circular com uma força gravitacional
muito forte e cam e consegue multiplicar
para fora e proporcionar para fora do
próprio microssistema efeitos
multiplicadores vários que depois acabam
pura é a impactar todos os sistemas
sociais políticos e econômicos
as três grandes forças que constitui um
pilar do equilíbrio desse sistema
circular e rotativo é tem a ver com a
renovação e do ensino universitário
levasse iniciativa a nível global mas
também a nível localizado mas também com
o equilíbrio entre os discursos
sobretudo daqueles que têm influência no
setor e que tem daí que tomam decisões
no setor e por outro lado também as
políticas efetivas que são implementadas
eu falo aqui de uma experiência muito
rápida de um país muito pequeno de uma
universidade 5 mil pessoas
nuno de cerca de 5 mil pessoas na
comunidade acadêmica e que tem
conseguido desenvolver rapidamente
equilibrado exatamente essas três forças
acreditar sobretudo que o circo lista
virtuoso do cefet rotativos e
retroativos transversais que são
propulsados pelo sistema universitário
são o cerne da questão está o segredo do
desenvolvimento do nosso país mas também
é uma comunidade uma comparticipação do
nosso micro sistema naquele que é um
sistema global de desenvolvimento do do
ensino superior e do ensino
universitário apoiar vários paradox à
volta dessa questão os paradoxos surgem
quando os cursos contrariam as
evidências dessa relevância quando se
aposta na na educa o ensino
profissionalizante o ensino técnico são
mais relevantes do conhecido superior
universitário
nós temos procurar o equilíbrio se
senhoras não haverá um bom ensino
técnico e profissionalizante
se não houver o ensino superior que
alimentos com qualidade a excelência da
investigação científica ea inovação
atrás desta transferência de tecnologia
a transferência de conhecimento novo
para a sociedade para as empresas
se o sim senhoras temos aqui é uma
universidade pequena mas que não se
esquece que os três pilares tradicionais
do seu desenvolvimento são o ensino à
investigação e à extensão universitária
e kuyt é o segredo do desenvolvimento e
sobretudo o segredo da relevância deste
sistema não se estendesse microssistema
no sistema global está exatamente na
procura do equilíbrio das forças que eu
acabei de mostrar e nessa procura do
equilíbrio que essa jovem universidade
tem é desenvolvido a sua estratégia de
desenvolvimento nós temos aqui uma
estratégia muito clara de
internacionalização uma estratégia muito
clara de focalização na compreensão e
quando nós falamos do coração
nós falamos da corporação nacional mas
também a nível internacional a nossa
aposta tem sido com precisão a
identidade do que diz respeito à
corporação nacional é o estabelecimento
do modelo de alianças entre a
universidade o estado às empresas a
sociedade civil
esse modelo da aliança permitirá que
juntos possamos refletir identificar
desafios comuns
e sobretudo identificar necessidades
comuns e juntos procuraram soluções cada
um
explorando capitalizando aquele que é o
seu modelo de negócio é aquele que é o
seu objetivo é a sua missão e nós
acreditamos que une um dos subsetores
substitui outro portanto a aposta tem
que ser num equilíbrio na
proporcionalidade do investimento em
todos os subsetores e o ensino superior
universitário não é substituível e não
pode ser é claramente substituído pelo
ensino técnico e pelo ensino
profissionalizante e vice versa
portanto nós temos tentado procurar
convencer a nossa sociedade tentado
procurar convencer o nosso sistema de
que ash este é o segredo é o equilíbrio
é a procura do equilíbrio e sobretudo o
respeito ea consciência da importância
fundamental de cada um dos subsetores a
nossa proposta tem sido na mobilidade no
que diz respeito à mobilidade
internacional tem sido localizada em
três grandes focos
o primeiro foco tem a ver com o reforço
da mobilidade internacional da
mobilidade acadêmica e dando os
intercâmbios científicos que nós
desenvolvemos com universidades e
instituições parceiras e isso tem
permitido jovem universidade de um país
tão pequeno como caveto perdidos nos 1
no atlético mas sobretudo enfrentando os
desafios da insularidade tem permitido
esta universidade enfrentar os desafios
do ensino universitário em nível local
mas também a nível mundial
o segundo foco nós temos definido tem a
ver com a o reforço da nossa
participação nas linhas internacionais a
que pertencemos mas também a integração
em novas redes em função da preferência
para o próprio desenvolvimento de cabelo
e da nossa universidade e concretamente
para podermos também acompanhar aquilo
que são os desafios do ensino superior a
nível mundial porque nós acreditamos que
a sobrevivência do nosso planeta depende
do cada um faz do cabelo e da conjugação
dos esforços de todos de todos os países
para que o planeta realmente viva com
instabilidade e nós forçados do
beneficiário e usufruir daquele que nos
oferece
em terceiro lugar vem eo terceiro grande
foco tv com estratégias concretas para
preparar a nossa comunidade ea nossa
universidade para poder integrar melhor
né nos programas de mobilidade
internacional e para isso nós instalamos
institutos de língua e literatura e
cultura que permitem aos membros da
nossa academia é aumentarem o nível de
performance em línguas estrangeiras e
para poderem participar com qualidade
naquilo que são os programas de
mobilidade internacional
por um lado por outro também permitir a
nossa academia preparadas para receber
estrangeiros que possam ter na
universidade kv a oportunidade de
estudar a língua portuguesa que é nossa
língua oficial em língua de transmissão
do conhecimento e da produção da ciência
e portais preparar a nossa necessidade
para também poder acolher com qualidade
e poder outros e é a oportunidade do
nivelamento a nível das vítimas mas
também temos estado a apostar em centros
de investigação do que queremos que
venham a ser no futuro de referência
estamos apostados num ano da construção
do ecossistema de investigação que nos
permita acompanhar os desafios que os
nossos parceiros que são que nós
tentamos que sejam os milhares tentarmos
identificar parceiros estratégicos entre
os melhores e queremos acompanhar também
o nível de desenvolvimento que ele já
atingiram por outro lado a matemática é
começar nenhum outro desafio do ensino
superior e não só da educação
de uma maneira geral não e nós estamos a
apostar a traiu com uma cooperação muito
estreita com o politécnico do porto né e
instalação já instalamos o instituto
josé brum e estamos a pensar é estamos a
acompanhar
ia participar também na instalação do
instituto josé braga e outros países
língua portuguesa como forma de reforçar
os a nossa internacionalização caxias e
senhoras e que nosso tempo pra
equilíbrio tempo para a mudança e nós
acreditamos que o equilíbrio lucro
segredo do equilíbrio está em pensar
juntos em refletir juntos e juntaram
esforços criaram os filhos de e podermos
juntos construir um sistema que seja
verdadeiramente porém a nível do ensino
universitário que possamos acreditar
verdadeiramente que é relevante a aposta
no ensino superior universitário para
que os efeitos multiplicadores positivos
que esse sistema rotativo provoca sejam
realmente impactante e que ajudem o
nosso planeta é sobreviver e te garanto
um sobretudo que a nossa geração possa
ser justa com as gerações que vêm a
seguir
muitíssimo obrigada foi um presente
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah